we have breaking news this morning on
julian assange the wikileaks founder
accused of
revealing u.s classified information
elizabeth palmer is in london where a
judge has just ruled in his case
elizabeth
what can you tell us
good morning yes well the verdict was a
surprise it prompted a huge
cheer among assange's supporters outside
the old bailey the central criminal
court
the judge's verdict says that julian
assange will
not be extradited to the united states
to stand trial
on mental health grounds she says that
he's depressed he's despairing
and that conditions in u.s jails
which she described as oppressive could
make him
a serious suicide risk if extradited he
would have faced
18 counts one of computer hacking on 17
espionage charges all relate to
classified documents he published on the
wiki
essentially which hinged on the fact
that he he
maintained he was protected by freedom
of speech laws
theoretically if he was found guilty he
could have faced more than a hundred
years in jail
in spite of that verdict though assange
did not walk out of court a free man
instead he was remanded straight back
into custody
because the u.s legal team announced
they are going to
apply they're going to appeal probably
as soon as this week so
this case is far from over gail all
right elizabeth palmer reporting from
london thank you